[Music]
what is up everybody i've been reading
the comments and i notice a trend
amongst those comments a lot of you want
to know what my pre-med journey was like
i'm incredibly happy that you want to
know my story
and i will be telling you everything
from why i went into medicine
uh what college was like what med school
was like
and give you some tips along the way
so right now i'm 27 years old uh i'm
fresh out of residency a couple months
out but i think
a good place to start would probably be
somewhere in high school maybe sophomore
year of high school
because i remember it was at that point
i was pretty firm
that i wanted to go into the field of
medicine and i'll tell you how i got
there
my dad is a doctor he was a doctor back
in russia before we even came to the
states
and when we came to the u.s he decided
to go through medical school for the
second time in his life and this is
in a new language he didn't speak
english in his 40s
i had a very unique perspective watching
my dad
go through medical school take all the
classes for the first two years
then go on his clinical rotation the
next two years and then
going into his residency i mean when it
was take your kid to work day
he brought me to the hospital in his
residency that's the good part about it
the bad was that i wasn't able to
complain
and if i ever did he's like shut up
because i did it in much harder
circumstances
with that i will not argue let me tell
you how i went into medicine
because or how i decided my heart was in
medicine first of all when i was in high
school
i loved science that was my number one
class
i performed best in that class and i was
always
curious about the human body i wanted to
know
why certain things happened why your
stomach hurt why your head hurt but
that's not what made me decide to go
into medicine when i saw my dad with his
patients and it happened quite
frequently i realized
medicine is a field that you can go into
and not have a responsibility to a
client
to a shareholder to a board member
but it was to the person sitting
directly in front of you and i started
to look into the different options there
are
to go into the field of medicine you
know you have
md schools you have do schools you have
caribbean
md schools but after spending some time
watching my dad go through do school
and doing some of the manipulations and
the hands-on omt things that we do as
does
on me after injuries in taekwondo and
soccer and seeing phenomenal results
i said i want to be a do and i became
really passionate
in finding a route that will get me to
be a doctor in the fastest way possible
in high school
i'm not going to lie i wasn't the
studious type i didn't spend hours
studying
a lot of the information pretty much
came to me i had a really good memory
because
when i was in middle school my dad
actually when he came home from med
school and he was exhausted he would
give me my social studies textbook ask
me what my required reading for that
night was
and then tell me that i have to memorize
each page
while he holds the book and i have to
rehearse and tell them
exactly word for word what's on that
page to some people in society they
might see that as something horrible oh
you're forcing your child to do this
when they don't want to but he was very
disciplined that way that he said you
want to have fun you have to do this
first i learned how to memorize
i i almost got a photographic memory at
one point when
i would read these pages and have to
tell them back i could imagine the page
in front of me
and doing that practice in middle school
really set me up for success in high
school
i decided in my junior year to start
applying to combined
bsdo programs bs is bachelors in science
and do
is doctor of osteopathic medicine and
it's basically a combined program
an accelerated program where you do
three years of undergraduate studies
and four years of medical school and all
you have to do is maintain
um a pretty significant gpa i believe
was like 3.5
and then get uh just like sort of a
mediocre
mcat score and continue i believe was
like 27 or 28 at the time
and i remember i applied early decision
to
nyit's bsdo program nyt being new york
institute of technology
it's an old westbury in long island in
new york
i believe they only accepted like 90
applicants or something around there so
it's very competitive
um i did fairly well on my sat i didn't
get like a 1600 or anything like that
but it was like mid-1400s
um so you know i did fairly well on that
my gpa was pretty solid
and i was lucky enough to get into the
nyt bsdo program
so college i took all the necessary
classes
i had to maintain a very high gpa of 3.5
couldn't let it drop below that and that
was obviously tough because
every class your grade was very
important to
your future you know it wasn't just oh
if i get a b
plus i'm fine like a b was not good a b
was a 3.0
so if you got a b you were worried how
that affected your gpa
i'm finishing up my third year
which is my last year of undergraduate
studies and i have to go in to take my
mcat
this is an incredibly stressful time for
everybody
some people didn't prep enough for the
mcat
some people chose that decided that
their
medical school wasn't for them and my
program suddenly shrunk from like
90 or 88 whatever it was that it started
with to like 20 but there
are certain things you can do to succeed
with your mcat number one
it's a predictable test there are kaplan
courses there are free courses online
there are boot camps that you can go to
and study for a couple of weeks at a
time
and i know some of these things cost
money and maybe you don't need the boot
camp that costs the most
but you can sign up for a kaplan class
and put in the time to hear people say i
can't do well on this test no matter
what i do if you find a tutor if you
find
an online study program there is no
reason
why you shouldn't get the score that you
need to to get into a medical school
people say well how do i know if
medicine is right for me that's a very
common question
um and it's a question that you need to
answer for yourself
i didn't know if medicine was right for
me so i watched my dad do it i
experienced it i worked in a medical
setting i knew what it felt like
at least a rough concept of what it's
like to work as a doctor
now there are some of you whose parents
are doctors there are some of you who've
heard from your friends that being a
doctor gets you
rich these are not good reasons to go
into medicine
i'm not saying that to discourage you
i'm just saying medicine is a
long-term commitment residency hours are
brutal
med school is a lot of studying
undergrad pre-med studying is a lot of
studying
and if you don't want to be there for
the right reasons my dad's a doctor my
mom's a doctor my sister's a doctor
grey's anatomy looks awesome dr oz looks
cool good reasons to go into medicine
you can't see yourself doing anything
else you have an insatiable curiosity
for the field of medicine you want to
make a difference in the world
and science falls within your skill set
those are good reasons
a big thing i have to tell you about
this maybe applies more to medical
school but i think it applies to college
as well
there will always be another test
there will always be another exam there
will always be something else you're
preparing for
if you start to stress out about every
single
test you won't make it through the
process or you'll make it through the
process and be really unhappy
or you'll make it through the process
and be really unhealthy because stress
really sucks long term so you shouldn't
expose yourself to that if you as an
undergraduate student who's looking to
go into medicine
start worrying about the test you have
next thursday and then start thinking
about the tests you have the following
month and then the following
month and then your mcats and then your
boards and then this and that
you'll go crazy approach each test
as an obstacle that's immediately in
front of you that you need to surpass
now you've taken the mcat you've gotten
your scores and it's time for you to do
interviews
my journey through interviews was i had
an interview
in nyit in med school which is more of a
formality
and yes they ask you some difficult
questions but again as long as you don't
say anything too wild you're guaranteed
a spot in the program because of the
seven year contract that
you've went into in the program but that
doesn't mean
i don't know what questions med schools
traditionally ask
all of that information is available to
you on the internet
scour student doctor network look on
different forums if you're going into an
interview
you have to know how to answer the
question
why do you want to be a doctor i mean
you have to know
if you don't know the answer to that or
if your answer is that my dad's a doctor
i mean that's awful like there's no way
around it you
have to know why you're there and you
have to be a person first
what does that mean that means when i
ask you a question whether that's
as an interviewer i ask you a question
like
why you want to go into medicine or why
this medical school
i don't expect you to have a brilliant
answer but i expect you to have an
answer that's based on your experiences
based on something that you did based on
something you felt
because if you tell me a generic answer
i'll know it's generic because i hear
those answers all the time
but if you tell me a unique answer that
might not even blow
my mind but it's unique to you
i know that i'm getting a human
applicant in front of me someone that
can
feel empathy who can verbalize what
they're feeling be human
be appropriate at times of sadness be
sad
when it's time to be angry be angry you
know have
experience all your emotions don't feel
like you need to put on a front
am i saying don't be professional and
use profanity and slang
no be professional i'm saying be you
in a sense that you should tell your
story it's not enough to just practice
having read questions and practice
answers within your mind
you have to verbalize it and that goes
for public speaking too visualize a
person in front of you asking you a
question
and answer it you'll stutter you'll no
doubt stutter
but that's a good thing get the
stuttering out now create your story so
it flows
once you've verbalized and your brain
has heard you say it
it forms that pattern those neurons link
together within your brain
and you will have a much easier time
verbalizing all those things at the time
of the interview
now it was time to get serious because
no one's holding your hand in medical
school if you start flunking
by you left if you don't pass your
boards
by i came in to medical school with the
philosophy
that i will over study and then sort of
decrease the amount of time necessary to
study for my exams
so i can find the best amount of time
that i need to
dedicate to do well on the exams but
also to have a substantial life
a healthy life outside of medicine as
well because that's important
you can't just bury your head in a book
for four years and forget society exists
there were a lot of people who were into
what you would call like performance
enhancing pills some people were taking
caffeine pills to increase their ability
to study longer
some people were taking legal things
like adderall without even a
prescription they were buying it on the
street
i urge you do not fall into this trap of
starting to take pharmaceuticals
in order to improve your performance in
med school it's going to make you
unhappy
you're going to build a dependence on
them you're gonna change the way you
view your success
and you feel like it's not rightfully
earned don't do that you will regret
your decision i've seen people do it
i've seen people get sick from it
it's not a smart choice so let me talk
about my med school experience and a lot
of medical schools work in a similar
fashion but
not all the first two years are learning
in the classroom
lecture based learning and then the
second two years
are clinical rotations that you spend in
the hospital and those hospitals
are ones that carry an affiliation with
your med school nyit
luckily had a lot of great clinical
affiliation so i was able to do
rotations at a lot of sites
my school was
great in the sense that it streamed all
of the lectures in addition to going and
viewing the lecture
i wasn't a fan of studying the packets
that they gave
so i watched the lectures on accelerated
speed and
a lot of people were like mike are you
crazy i don't even understand what
they're saying when you put it on 1.5
speed or two speed but look it worked
for me
i was able to watch the lectures two
times over
in the time that most people watch them
in a single session if you have a dream
school great
i'm happy that you're dreaming i'm happy
i'm happy you have a goal
but if you don't get into your number
one or even your number two or number
three school
it's not the end of the world it really
almost doesn't make a difference
if you want to learn in this day and age
all the material is there for you
yes you should go to the best school
that you can for your circumstances
you know what your abilities are what
your surroundings are like where your
physical location is
uh unfortunately to say how much
financial ability you have
but if you don't get your number one
school don't panic work hard
work harder but don't think it's the end
of the world i promise you it's not so
you finish your
first two years of learning and now
comes
my favorite part step one boards
this is a tough phase because not only
are you studying for your current
classes and trying to do well there
but you also have to study for your
boards and your step one exam is
probably the most important exam
that is going to decide which residency
you get which residency you go into in
the future it's not the only thing that
matters but it's one of the most
important things
so it's one of those tests similar to
the mcat that people freak out about
and it's important to not do that it's
important to prepare the more questions
you do
the more preparations you get the better
you're going to do on the test
that's the bottom line especially if
you're already doing well in your
current classes the number one advice i
can give you
is do questions questions questions
because it's been proven
in scientific trials that
recognition and fetching that idea from
your mind
retrieving it bringing it back to paper
in a question form
is the best way of memorizing material
so don't be afraid to do
two question banks even if you need to
in your third year you start something
known as clinical rotations
where you'll get a schedule of either
one hospital or multiple hospitals and
different departments that you're going
to be rotating in
this was my favorite part of medical
school because i love experiencing stuff
i love getting stuff done my first
rotation was internal medicine
where you're treating hospitalized
patients for all sorts of illnesses
i didn't come in pretending i knew
everything or i didn't come in with an
attitude i'm eager to learn
and what i don't know i promise i'll
learn in the future the residents really
like that about me because
when they needed help uh i would all
volunteer my services as much as i could
without obviously being annoying or
overstepping bounds or
pushing other students learning uh
before my i mean after mine
i always try to make it fair but anytime
that i can help somebody out stay late
do an extra procedure
i would do it so i can learn it or if i
didn't know how to do it i asked if i
could watch someone do it
and that old mantra of uh watch uh
see one do one teach one really applies
here
when i saw a resident do it i learned
how to do it then the resident would
watch me do it
approve of how i did it and next time i
would teach another student how to do it
and really that's the ultimate way to
learn by repeating that process over and
over again enjoy the process man that's
like
that's the thing i have to tell you i
would hear some people say i just want
to get out of here i want to get out of
here early
or i don't want to come in so early this
rotation sucks
you chose this career you wanted to be
here this is what you want to do this is
what you're going to be doing your whole
life
how can you be complaining about being
here when you said you wanted to be here
a topic that i need to touch on
and i want you to pay attention to very
carefully is
do not be a gunner let me define what a
gunner is
a gunner is a person a medical student
usually
who will do anything to succeed
will throw their fellow students
underneath the bus underneath the bus
we'll throw their fellow students under
the bus they'll
speak out of turn to make residents look
bad
they'll tell somebody something negative
about somebody in order to get ahead
don't be that person medicine is a
community
build each other up if you see a
weakness in somebody
help them fix it and for god's sakes i
see this happen a lot
somebody will read some chapter in a
textbook think they're
experts on a subject and then start
critiquing residents attendings
lecturers about something that they just
read and they think they're an expert on
when someone that has 20 years of
clinical experience is telling them
otherwise
look don't get me wrong you can get
really knowledgeable by reading a
textbook
but it doesn't replace real life
knowledge plus
don't make someone feel stupid just
because you know something when you
looked at the day before so don't try
and show somebody up that's a gunner
don't be a gunner so during your third
year you'll have some time
for electives and going on these
different rotations
where you can sort of figure out what
career trajectory you want
at this point you'll know your step one
score you'll know
what that step one score can get you
residency wise this is where it's really
important
that when you go to all these hospitals
you go all these clinical sites as you
leave a good impression
you leave the impression that you're
eager to learn that you're eager to get
better some people call these showcase
electives where if you want to do a
certain residency in a hospital
you go do your clinical rotation there
and you show them your abilities your
skills
your ability to lead your ability to do
hands-on things that's a good time
to make connections that's a good time
to show off your personality that's a
good time to see if you're a good fit at
the program
remember you're still learning about
yourself even though the program is
equally learning about you at the same
time
i did my family medicine rotation i fell
in love
i said that you know i i love the
ability to influence someone's life
outside of just talking about their
disease
i fell in love with the field i fell in
love with my ability to commun
communicate with patients to grow older
alongside with my patients i made a lot
of the electives uh
that i had planned to be family medicine
and i i did those electives
in a bunch of different hospitals just
so i can see how family medicine was
practiced
in different areas in new york i even
did a rotation in florida
and that's when time comes and you have
to
um you know do your showcase electives
where you show
your abilities to the programs for that
month that you essentially want to do
residency in
and the last part of that would be
filling out the match paperwork so i
went into the match
ranked some of these programs it's a
time where you have to do some soul
searching you have to get ready for your
interviews all over again
get used to talking about yourself get
used to talking about your
accomplishments again like i said before
verbalize so i went on these interviews
went to interviews in florida when
interviews in new york new jersey
picked overlook couldn't be happier now
looking back four years later
best choice i made i was so happy with
my training there
i'd love to tell you more about my
residency and my social media and how
all that came together but i feel like
that warrants its own video
if you're curious to see that leave a
comment down below as you can tell i'm
very active in the comment section
i try to answer all uh serious questions
you know i get a lot of you jokers out
there but i even answer those so i
really hope
that you enjoyed this long video i know
it's longer than most of my other videos
but it was an opportunity for me to tell
you my story
so thank you for listening hope you got
some great tips and
points from this video that you can use
in your own life and do even a better
job in med school than i did
so stay happy stay healthy see you next
week
med school is not for the weak
this is what med school does to you kids
j
point elevations can be a normal variant
in an ekg in a young adult but it could
also mean
that you're more susceptible to a sudden
cardiac death talk to your doctor
you